[Music]
the pharma company a buret abbott
laboratory says it's created a new
portable coronavirus test that can
deliver results in minutes rather than
days so how does it work does it work
we've decided to find out live on air
tonight dr. Mike mosaic is associate
chair of pathology at Newton Wesley
Hospital outside Boston I'll be
performing the test on this shows chief
medical contributor dr. mark Segal dr.
Massiah thanks so much for coming on
tonight walk us through what this is how
you administer it
what happens next so this is a rapid
diagnostic test that will generate an
accurate diagnosis within five minutes
if the patient is positive for kovat and
up to 13 minutes if they are negative
and it's the only test out there that's
rapid in in in that degree of speed how
do you administer it so the way it works
is that dr. Siegel here is kind enough
to be our patient for this evening and
he had actually complained of a bit of a
cough and is thinking about going back
on the wards at NYU so we thought it
would be a good idea to definitively
rule him out for Co bed and we're gonna
use the Abbott here and get a result
with within a few minutes so the way it
works is that we will swab him and we'll
do a nasal swab and put it in the
instruments and I'm just putting on my
PPE here because this is a potentially
infectious process and we want to adhere
to all of our PPE guidelines so the
first step here is that we will take a
swab
okay so the swabs all set now and we can
okay so look I just asked you to pause
there
so you didn't I just poked some of the
other day who had one of these tests
with a swab went all the way back into
his throat that's not necessary with
this yeah so that's one of the beauties
of this instrument is actually it is
validated for nasal swabs the swab that
you're mentioning that goes to the back
of the throat that's called a nasal
pharyngeal swab and that can be very
uncomfortable for patients and that's
the main reason why health care
providers when we when we perform it
have to wear PPE because it can induce
sneezing or coughing right okay so
you're gonna run that test and and we're
gonna we'll you I mean will you be you
have some sort of answer in ten minutes
15 minutes yeah yeah you know in in
about 15 minutes we'll we'll put it in
here we'll run it I'll show you how it
works so the test basically we open up
this chamber and we will put some
reagent in the base of it will swirl the
swab around it heats up we moved the
testing device up into this top one we
close it push the button and walk away
and within 15 minutes we will have a
result for dr. Siegel and he can be off
anyway the beauty of the rapid test is
that it can be used in multiple ways at
my particular Hospital we use it for
inpatients and for inpatients coming
into the emergency room who need to be
quickly assessed whether they have the
infection or not so that they can be
placed in a particular area of the
hospital it's invaluable in that sense
and it conserves PPE because if we know
who's positive and who's negative we
know who we have to be cautious about
why it makes total sense and we'll be
back in just a minute
to find out what happened the case of
dr. Siegel doctor thank you appreciate
it
we've got a fox news alert for you dr.
Siegal's coronavirus test results are
back we don't know what they are we're
joined now by our chief medical
correspondent dr. Siegel he's back to
tell us with the mask off dr. Siegel
you're smiling Tucker that's a good sign
it's negative and I want to tell
everyone out there with a cough who's
worried that they were in contact with
people with kovat 19 this is where the
future has to be boy do I feel great
boy if I'd been worried for a week not
wanting a coffin public not wanting
anyone to know about it you know what
this means I can go back to social
distancing and not think so much about
social quarantine which is what I would
have had to do if I were positive dr.
Redfield of CDC who I spoke to today
feels that this swab I did is just as
accurate as the more invasive swab which
you asked and Admiral gerar of HHS said
the same thing the other tests I'm doing
tonight is that I'm having my blood
drawn so that dr. Messala can check me
for antibodies and then I can see
whether I'm immune or on the road to
being immune if I had it already that's
the future here we got to know did I
have it am I getting over it can I go
back to society if I have that
information on everyone and Tucker look
how long this took not even the length
of the show and I know I'm negative
Wow mate that's got to be the major for
our society that will help us recover
that will help us recover for sure it's
a prerequisite to recovery
I must know ten people who would like
that test very quickly how long till
those ten people can get it well let's
hope within the next few weeks we're
being told that it will be rolled out
very very quickly this test is limited
because it can only do for an hour on
this right but we need these all over
the place we have 18,000 of them in the
country we need 800 200,000 as soon as
possible or tests just like it for rapid
test results point-of-care amazing Abbot
what Abbott Laboratories good for them
dr. Siegel great to see you tonight
thank you very relieved Thank You Tucker